okay hi everyone um sorry that I cannot
attend in live H hope that I can
communicate well and Via zoom and if you
have any further question I will be
happy to answer them on slack on mail or
whatever okay um you are not in the
slideshow mode yeah okay okay that's
okay now yeah yeah okay um so I'm going
to present a um a new idea this is
actually a vision paper but I'm going to
give you some concrete result that we
have so far and this is a collaboration
with mic farella from MIT and Baba
salimi from San Diego and anazon which
is a PhD student at
Mat
okay and so I'm going to start um with
some motivation why do we need those
coal data integration and the main theme
is related to to what we hear so far
today is about explanation we want to
explain a query result so I'm going to
start with explanation on correlation
and then I'm going to talk briefly about
causal explanation and why we really
want caal explanation and then I'm going
to focus on the caal data integration
motivated by the caal explanation why we
need this a new line of
research so we talked about SQL queries
that I'm going to focus on aggregate CLE
queries um which can be seen as a way to
expose correlation in in the data and
this is based on on a recent work with
um M farella and yal mosovich and Baba
and the idea is that we want to
understand unexpected correlation
observed in in user query but in many
cases a a it's the reason the only
reason that we're seeing those
unexpected correlation is because of
conf found in bias that means there are
other factor that affecting the result
and the only reason that we see two
variables that changes together is
because there are other variable that
can explain it so I'm going to give you
some a nice example that I like to share
and this is a real life example and this
is based on a study that looks on data
of a people asking for par and they went
to courot and there um and then they
look on the poll in the time of the day
and the decision made by the judges and
then the aors of this paper look at the
data set and they concluded that closer
to noon time when people are the the
judges are hungry H the probability of
the decision to be rejected are higher
so the natural conclusion of them is
that hungry judges when they are hungry
are tougher and you don't want to get to
a parole near
noon um so this is a correlation they
saw in the data between the probability
time of the day and the probability of
the decision to be rejected and then a
few months later um another group of
author look at the same exact data set
and they discover that the only reason
that they saw this correlation is
because there are other factor that they
did not consider like the order that
people come to the court is not random
people arrive to the court by different
a um different Court H different jails
in different time of day people that
have lawyer usually come early in the
morning and Etc ET and if you take those
confounding variables into account you
actually discover there is no
correlation at all between the time of
the day and the probability of the the
parole to be denied and of course there
is no everyone expected the first paper
is highly cited everyone think that
hungry judges make are tougher but no
one really talks about the second paper
that reveals that there is actually no
correlation at all so the takeaway of
this story is that we have to keep in
mind that we want to expand some
correlation we have to ask ourself is
there maybe there is another way to
explain the correlation that we seen
through a unobserved variable that can
completely explain the
relationship so back to SQL H let's
consider a fly data set that we have a
flights operate in the US by large
Airline carrier and we see on the left
side an aggregate sqle query that simply
computes the average a departure delay a
group by CD and we can see there is a
big difference between cities and the
the question the natural question is why
does the choice of the Depart of city
has such a strong effect on the
departure delay so again it can be seen
like a correlation between the city and
the average day and and we want to try
to explain what explained this
correlation that we see in the data so
we call the depart City in this case I'm
going to call it the treatment and the
departure delay is the the outcome and
we want to explain the connection
between those two variables in the data
set but our key observation is that in
in many real life scenarios and in this
scenario as well important variables
might be missing from the data and in
this example weather related variables
like the temperature visibility or air
airport traffic like that can be a that
that can be approximated by for example
the population density and size are
missing from the data and maybe those
kinds of variable can completely explain
the relationship between departure City
and and departure
delay so there is a lot of work and and
also Benny and Daniel Amir talked about
there's a lot of work about explaining
the result of a a of SQL query and and
those work all look on the input data
try to explain the result and and what
we wanted to do in this in this paper is
not looking only on the input data and
but also look on external data sources
like Knowledge Graph or data l so or any
web table anything that can be related
maybe can give us a hint on to explain
the unexpected correlation seen in the
data so at a very high level what we did
we automatically M unobservables only
from Knowledge Graph in this work and
then after a getting hundreds of maybe
relevant maybe not relevant variables we
reach data set then the the main goal
was to identify only a small subset of
variables that explain the correlation
that we' seen in the query so more
formally we we're given a set of
candidate attribute from the input data
set or attribute that we extracted from
related data data sources and then we
want to find a subset of attribute that
minimizes the conditional Mutual
information between the treatment and
the outcome in this case is the
departure delay in the departure
City and I'm going to skip on the
algorithm if if you want to hear more
about about the algorithm I can do it
offline H but continue with our
example so for this query the
explanation that we find was the set of
three variables which is the population
size which is a proxy for the air
traffic the bigger the city H the bigger
the population we get more air traffic
the year low Fahrenheit which is again a
a some some attribute to describe the
weather in in the city and the airline
carrier and intuitively that means that
in city that are at the same size that
have a similar weather condition and if
you're using the same airline you are
expected to get the same departure delay
it's not it's not a full explanation
it's not cannot fully explain the
correlation because there are other
unobserved variables like for example
security or unexpected event but those
variable explain most of the the
unexpected correlation seen in the
data Okay
so the main issue with what I told you
so far is that we were focusing on
correlation and we wanted to explain the
correlation and I talked about confound
in bias but we actually had no
assumption on any causal
relationship and of course I if I want
to just predict the departure delay a
good way to dep to to predict the
departure delay is look at the arrival
delay so of course if the the flight
departure late the arrival delay most
likely will also I will also experience
a delay of of course of the same flight
but it doesn't mean that the arrival
delay has a caal relationship to
departure delay so in order to really
draw causal conclusion we have to have
some Co causal reasoning about that
about the the attribute that we're
considering Beyond just observing the
correlation in the data so in an ongoing
project with M farella and Amir gilad
and and sudipa and this is still a um
under submission we're looking for
causal explanation instead of just
explaining the correlation we actually
want to draw Co and conclusion from the
data so example question that we want to
answer is what are the factor they
influence the salaries of developers in
in in in different countries or what are
the factor that affecting the departure
delay in in different cities and in
order to answer those kind of question
we have to be able to quantify the de
effect so for example we have to be able
to quantify the effect or how much that
having a master degree impact the salary
of of a developer in the
US
so um our over overreaching goal is
given a data set and some a a group by
average query we want to explain the
view by causal explanation a set of
causal explanation so for example H
looking at this dat this data set and
this query a a an example explanation
for a subset of tles in the query result
in this case our countries around the
world is to say that for countries in in
Europe a being individual under the age
of 55 with a master degree posit
positively affect the salary in this
case um on average their salary is
higher by a
36k but on the other end be the student
has a strong negative effect on the
salary in this case if you're a student
your salary will be 39K minus the
average salary in countries of Europe so
more formally what we want to say that
giv a data set in a group by query and
number k and a threshold we want to find
a set of
explanation that has no more than
individual K explanation we want to
expand at least a Theta fraction of the
tles in the query answer with no
redundancies and and intuitively we want
to make sure that the overall
explainability is maximized and when I
saying overall explainability I'm
talking about the causal effect that we
are reporting we want to find those
treatments those a intervention that
causes the highest impact on the outcome
if it's the departure delay or the
salary we want to find what really
changes it to be what would really
causing it to be high or
low so let's just FOC focus on one
specific caal question that we want to
answer how much does choice of an
airline carrier affect the flight
departure delay and to be able to answer
that we we are adopting a a pearl um a
pearl model for a
coal for for cality on observational
data
so I'm just going to briefly talked
about how we can do it and and then I'm
going to talk and then I'm going to move
on to the caal data integration and and
why we need a coal data
integration so let's assume that I want
to compute the effect of a um a American
Airlines and United Airlines their their
choice of on their choice of this
Airline carrier on the departure DeLay
So hyp hypothetically what I can do for
every flight I could randomly decide if
this flight will be operated by United
Airlines or by American Airline and then
I can measure what is the um what is the
average delay and Report which one of
the airline has a longer average delay
but of course you can't really do it um
but we can use randomized experiment so
in In a randomized experiment what I
wanted to do because I can only observe
one a a airline carrier for each one of
the flight I want to say that if I can
randomly assign either American Airline
or a United Airlines I will randomly
assign that and then I will measure the
average delay and the expected average
day and this will be the average
treatment and the average treatment
effect which is the causal effect that I
want to measure but as as I just said we
can't really do it in practice in in
many scenario so instead we're using
Pearl a um um PE model for inferent
causal effect over observational data
and in which case what we want to
measure what we want to measure is the
average delay of using air American
Airlines or United airine when we're
taking into account all the confounding
variable and I need to know in order to
answer that I need to know what is the
set of confounding variable that I need
to take into account and this is the the
variable Z here it could be the weather
condition it could be um the security
delay or any other variable that can
affect it and this is the main question
that how can we know what is this set of
compounding variable that we need to
account to so in order to answer this
question what we what we need is a in PE
model we need a causal dag that describe
the causal relationship between the
variable that we have in our data set
and then we can identify the sufficient
set of variable to account for in order
to answer a causal
question so in theory to provide a cal
explanation what we need is a data set
with the treatment and the outcome and
we need this a codal d and then we can
identify a a sufficient adjustment set
and then we can using PE model we can
compute the causal effect that we need
to provide a causal
explanation but what we have in practice
is some kind of incomplete data set with
it could be with a lot of missing
variables and no caal duag at at all so
the purpose of causal data integration
is to bridge this gap of we want to Pro
to to be able to answer a causal
question but we have an an incomplete
view of the world and no causal Dag
and to get to this a um to this coal dag
and this complete data set we can do it
manually but it's take a lot of time and
effort and what we offer with the caal
data integration is an automatic tool to
do those two step um at the same
time so there are many challenges in
order to achieve this um this vision and
the first challenge is the completeness
we want to make sure that all the
relevant variable will be included in
our data set we don't want to miss some
relevant variable because we already
talked about the confounding Biers so we
want to make sure that the the the
completeness every relevant variable is
observed will be included in the data
set the Second Challenge is the
robustness we need to handle many data
issues a um because we we're going to
join our input t with with um multiple
variables from different sources so it
could be that we're going to have a many
missing values or outliers or some some
wrong values or a complex dependencies
like one to many relations or many many
to relation and we need one H one table
with all the variables so we need a
principal way to handle
those those issue to ensure that the
causal inference is
reliable and the third challenge is the
conciseness so every mistake that I'm
going to do in the coal dag can affect
my causal
estimation
and a common way to achieve this caal
dag is to use there is tons of existing
caal Discovery algorithm so I can use
this offthe shelf caal Discovery
algorithm or even C GPT or any other
algorithm that can provide us the coal
Coal dag but now we want to verify that
this tag is correct and align with our
domain knowledge but if if I have too
many variable and the dag is too big I
cannot manually spec the dag and make
sure the dag is is
correct so I'm going to give some a few
more details about about each one of the
challenges so for the completeness um
let's assume that this is the data set
that we start with and this is actually
a projection of the flight data set and
I can extract multiple um variable so
without any additional variable I can
look at the data set and I can I can
wrongly come to the conclusion that
American Airlines has a a has a strong
effect on the departure delay because
all flight operated by American Airlines
has a a a bigger um Department delay
compared to the other Airline carrier
and then I can join this table with
multiple other variable to see if I can
expand this correlation maybe there are
other unobserved confounding variable
that can explain the
correlation so one example is maybe the
departure dates maybe those flight that
I'm looking at for American Airline
operate around Christmas time which it
is well known that around this time of
year there we um passenger experience
longer DeLay So this is an example of
one variable that can be extracted and
joined to the table another variable is
the passenger sentiment maybe all the
passenger that travel with American a
airline reported low
sentiment and even though that this
variable is highly correlated with the
the outcome and um the treatment we need
to we need to see that correlation it's
not enough to make sure that this
variable is relevant to join to our
table because there is no causal
relationship here most likely that the
pass sentiment was measured only after
the departure delay only after the
flight so therefore this is not a
relevant variable to include in our data
set because we only want to include
those variable that are relevant to the
to the caal estimation in this case this
variable is not
relevant
um so that means that when joining the
the the variable we need to make sure
that first we want to know that what is
the source of the what is the source of
the variable that we are joining and and
maybe to this Source we can assign some
probalistic to see what is the how sure
that those value are correct or not
correct and also how the extractor
operates and this will give us some hint
or maybe this variable measured only
after the flight operates and then we
can we can assume that there is a causal
relationship between between the
departure delay to the passenger
sentiment and not the other way
around another variable could be the
weather condition um in this case H
assume that all the flight operate under
American Airline was operated I either
under heavy snow or thunderstorm and
this can completely explain why those
flight had experienced a longer
departure
delay okay um so for the Second
Challenge the robustness and this is a a
an active ongoing research with Anna
fahira and Yuval mosovich that we are
currently looking at and we want to to
resolve thata issue that can that can
affect a a causal estimation and we are
arguing that that existing um that
existing tool might be not enough to to
deal with causal with causal inference
and the main reason behind it is that
cause and conclusion compared with for
example prediction are more sensitive to
data issues so one example is the
selection bias and selection bias can
occure when when we we see that we tried
to to come up with a a conclusion that
observed on non-representative portion
of the population so if we want to
estimate a causal effect over
non-representative population of course
we can end up with a wrong
conclusion so assume that for H this
data set now I have the weather
conclusion the weather con the weather
condition column but I only observe the
weather condition for American Airlines
and and for heavy snow and thunderstorm
and I don't have the weather condition
for any other
flight five minutes left okay sure so
one way to deal thank you s one way to
deal with missing value is just to drop
all the missing value or try to impute
the missing value based on a the observe
value but here if the missing mechanism
is unknown we can actually draw wrong
conclusion and here for example the
missing mechanism could be that I only
observe the weather condition if the
weather condition were extreme so all
the the nonv values are actually should
be completed with clear H with clear
weather so this requires some a um
dedicated solution to handle with that a
issue if the task in hand is coal
inference and I'm going to move next to
the last challenge about the concise net
so as I mentioned the caal D might be
incorrect and we want to enable this Co
and work to be manually verified so an
idea is to Let's summarize the dou and
this is another ongoing research with
anang Mella and Baba and the main idea
is that we want to summarize this coal
dog and intuitively I'm just going to
give you the high level idea that what
we're trying to do we want to make sure
that the input coal DG will be
summarized to be have no more than K
notes we want to make sure that only
semantically relevant nodes are are
merged together and we want to make sure
that we retain the max maximum amount of
caal in
information and the way we do it we want
to make sure that all the conditional
Independence which is a a data
properties that are encoded in this coal
dog are recoverable from this summarized
coal dog and there is a lot of
competition and challenge in order to
achieve this goal because the number of
such conditional independencies is
exponential so how can we even count it
and because we summarized the D we need
to to define a new way how to read off
the summarized dou all the conditional
independences it it it
implies okay so to summarize um as I
said we in order to answer a causal
question we need to have this single and
complete relational database and a
correct causal dag but we start with
incomplete data set with no causal dag
and and this is how this is when Co data
integration might be
useful H and intuitively what we're
doing um so the knowledge extractor this
is a way that we start we want to
extract all H the
relevant possibly relevant variables
from data Lakes from Knowledge Graph or
for any other data source to address the
completed challenge the data organized
or organizer this is the model that
wants to edit the it wants to to account
to the robustness challenge and then we
have the summary a coal D builder in
order to build this summarized coal D
which will be easier H to work
quit
um so to summarize H in this talk I
introduced the caal data integration
which is a new research direction to
mind and organize data for causal
inference H unlike conventional data
integration we need to curate only
causally relevant variables not any
correlated variable as a um as we show
not not any correlated variable is
relevant here and also we want to make
sure that the end Co D will be aable and
concise to to enable a a reliable causal
causal
inference there are many other open
problems like how to extract relevant
and interpretable variables for from
text for images from log data how to
deal with complex dependencies or
probalistic data H and how to bridge the
gap between a scenario when we see that
we have some gaps between our data and
our domain knowledge um and this is just
a handful of examples of open problems
that are still needs to be
account H thank you very much for
listening and if you have any question I
will be happy to answer any question in
the open discussion that we have or via
email question for
breit hi Bri nice talk so I have a
question about the causal dag finding so
now that um we have like llm like models
and often the data properties are
semantically meaningful like Airline
delay and stuff like that so do you
anticipate that llm could help us find
this causal dag or something along that
line hi thank you Anna yeah thank you so
much for the question so maybe it wasn't
clear for first of all you are right llm
might be very very useful and in our
demonstration we actually use the lmm to
try to understand the similarity between
the nodes and also to get some topic for
the nodes that we cluster together and
they were very useful in terms of
infering the causal relationship between
two variables we found those LMS not to
be enough there is another paper that I
can share with you that they saw the
same phenomena and the main idea is that
those coal D cannot distinguish between
direct effect and indirect effect if you
asking if something is the cause of
something they cannot distinguish
between is it direct cause or is it
indirect cause so relying only on large
language Model H to build this coal dug
might be not enough but the focus of our
research is is not to build a coal dug
because this is a completely different
line of research for causal Discovery
and we're assuming that we have some
black box to to build this CA it could
be using large language model or any
other caal Discovery algorithm and we
focus on the task of graph
summarization um
but answering to your question and this
is and this is something that we
actually saw in real life data sometimes
you get this a causal Discovery
algorithm that tells you oh there is a
causal relationship between variable X
and variable y but it doesn't align with
your domain knowledge or with what you
get from a a c GPT and then the main
question is what what do you do with it
how can you align between your domain or
between large language model and what we
see in the data maybe the data is wrong
maybe you you have a selection bias or
maybe the large language model give you
indirect caal relationship and and I
don't have the answer what to do in this
case but I think that this is a
fascinating direction for future work um
how how we can answer that and I will be
happy to talk with you about it
offline okay so let's move on to the
discussion session we will spend 10 15
minutes to see uh to